(cars driving on pavement)
- [Man] More and more people are
taking a control of their lives
and not simply
working for the man.
I have sitting next to me today
one among you who certainly
knows what it's like to be
the keeper of his own destiny.
- [Gary] I would argue that if
you're going out on your own
you have to recognize
that it's very difficult
to create a cushion.
You gotta go.
You gotta go all in and if you
fail you have to reset and
maybe you go a different course.
Plan B needs to be in place of
what you're going to do but you
can be putting energy
towards it because plan A
needs all that energy.
Just announcing some
promotions on three hours sleep.
DRock's always here.
(techno music)
I actually thought I
was taping one here.
I actually woke up
early by accident--
- [Marcus] For like no reason
- and then was like fuck it
and then took a shower
because I woke up
a little early.
- [Marcus] This is
your second shower today?
- Yes.
(DRock and Marcus laughing)
Yes. This is my
second shower.
(techno music)
- Like you came in 11.
(Gary laughing)
- [Marcus] It's funny I thought
I was studying for the draft.
I was looking at all these
players and their reviews and...
- Talk to me about the most
ghetto situation from an,
I would say our first three or
four years were pretty ghetto.
- Yeah.
- What was the most ghetto
situation from our office space?
Give me a ghetto
office space story.
- I'm trying to think.
There was a lot of people
who slept in the office.
- Yes.
- I slept in the
office a few times.
You couldn't sleep, this is in
Tribeca, but you couldn't sleep
in the middle because the lights
stayed on all year so there was
a little office room that was
like probably 10' x 10' and it
was the only place that light
wouldn't get into and so you had
to sleep in there.
- Why did you guys sleep there?
Because it was nicer
than your apartments?
- Yeah. All of our
apartments really far away.
- If your true practitioner,
if you're not a headline reader
'cause you read something once
that said it's not doing well or
some company did poorly with
it or your friend run a hundred
bucks worth of ads on
Facebook and said didn't work.
If you got out of being a
headline reader and became a
true practitioner you would know
what I and we know which is this
is driving real-life results
and very honestly
I have put no passion for.
I only have passion
for your attention.
If you all stopped going to your
cell phone and social networks
I wouldn't even remember
what it was called.
These are not places that
are nice to haves or maybes.
These are prerequisites for
being relevant at all in 2016
and cannot be nine
minutes of your time.
It's been really it's been so
fun to watch 'cause there hasn't
been something this big
since Instagram and it got
bought by Facebook so fast.
- Yeah.
- It's kind of fun to watch
the first major platform.
There's not that many of these.
There's not that many things
that you can watch everybody
over time get on.
It's been a long time since
early Facebook, early Twitter.
- [Man] (inaudible)
- I do. Yeah, I do. I do.
I think it just started.
Tony, I'm taking
over your account.
Promise you're going
to make more snaps.
Promise.
- Come on man, you
got to be current.
You gotta keep it real.
(Gary and Tony laughing)
- I love it.
- Boom, taking it over.
Look at GV, man.
- Understand these things
are already at scales that
very few things ever get to.
Snapchat is already bigger
than Tumblr has ever been.
These are really big platforms
and I think we're also in a
different place with this.
Unlike when Twitter and
Facebook did their thing,
the scale of the phone is so
intense. We used to do that.
I used Twitter for the first
two years mainly on desktop.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's so crazy.
But I promise you in a world
where this is the communication
not what you think you're doing.
When this phone and these
channels is the communication
I'd like to follow you
on your eight hour day.
I have a funny feeling
there's an hour there that
you could be
deploying to learning.
Make up life.
Right, DRock?
- [DRock] Right.
- You need some
make up DRock.
- [DRock] Nope.
- If you're a true
bred entrepreneur
as a journalist,
as a pundit,
as a thinker,
as an educator,
as a social commentator
you're different.
- Right.
- But if you're an
entrepreneur, a pure bred,--
- Right.
- and you're crying about
this, you've already lost.
- Quick question
about marketing--
- Do you understand?
- Yes, I understand.
- It's an important point.
Because the market is way
harder than old some white
dudes giving you money.
- Right.
- You know what's crazy you're
going to love this.
You're going to love this,
how aligned we are. Ready?
I started VaynerMedia here.
I started running it.
I ran it here.
AJ was super sad
because VaynerMedia
we didn't raise any money.
It's a client service business,
it didn't need any money.
- Yeah.
- In here all the (bleep),
(bleep) and all the homies are
rich on paper and AJ's like
you dragged me into this bull,
I mean client service sucks.
Here we are all got fucked up.
VaynerMedia this year is going
to do 100 million in revenue.
- Alright brother give
me a hug and kiss.
- Love you baby.
- Take care of yourself,
I'll see you soon.
I think in the last several
years I've been positioned
as a social media expert and
I'll be very honest with you
and frank, TechCrunch
audience, I don't like that.
I don't want to be a guru.
I don't want to be a pundit.
I'm a business operator.
As a kid, I built a
$65 million year business
without any venture capital,
without any M&amp;A activity.
I'm an entrepreneur.
I spent the last four years
building an agency with
no cash infusion from a
three to $100 million business.
I'm a businessman.
And so in this book I
talked about how I do that.
It's HR. It's actually
caring about people.
It's leadership.
It's having product vision.
I knew in 2009 that people would
spend $100,000 a month on their
social media budgets if
they were a big company.
Most people didn't.
The book really covers
leadership, self-awareness,
I talk a lot about emotional
intelligence, a lot about EQ.
I talk about the things
that I'm worried about.
You know what
I'm worried about?
If you're watching this,
TechCrunch, if you're watching
this you're in the
entrepreneurial ecosystem.
You know what we're not
talking about enough?
We're not talking how hard
it is to be an entrepreneur.
How few businesses win.
I feel a sense of responsibility
to talk about the fact that kids
have depression and even we have
kids and grown-ups committing
suicide in our space because
were not talking practical
enough about business.
Just 'cause you raised money
doesn't mean you're going to
have a successful business.
Everything you do will define
who you are for life but you got
to work hard and fast and
extreme on a micro level.
Be prepared mentally
for a marathon by
running a sprint day-to-day.
Bro, I miss you.
I miss you so much.
You look so handsome.
(woman laughing)
- The Internet is distribution.
There is no ABC.
There is no Fox.
There is no Viacom.
There is no satellites.
There is no printing press.
There's no Hearst Media.
There's the Internet and then
on top of the Internet
there's things like Facebook
and Instagram but much like
cable television, like unlimited
channels, if ESPN or A&amp;E and
Bravo come along they become
competitors for that attention
and that now is musically, right?
Nobody knows what's
going on musically.
But I do and I can tell you
right now in 24 months
there's going to
be make people
making millions dollars
a years off of musically.
And 98% of the readers that are
going to read your article have
never heard of it and the 2%
that have heard of it,
it's only 'cause they have 8 to
13-year-old girls in their home.
I've been surprised by how many
people have bought into well
I'm going to work smart, not hard.
The people that are
winning are doing both.
Go take a really cold shower.
I promise you
you're not outsmarting me.
The problem is that you're
just not outworking me.
I think the biggest surprise is
how many people think there's
some random system how
there's some crazy algorithm
or process that's going to
create passive income.
That they're so smart and that's
why they'll be able to have more
time to surf and be on
boats and enjoy their wealth.
I've been surprised by people's
naiveté that hard work
isn't part of the equation.
(techno music)